[Music]
good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret Baier President Trump says it's
time to rebuild America after spending
trillions in Iraq and Afghanistan
president is rolling out a massive
infrastructure and permitting reform
package it calls for state and local
governments and private industry to pay
most of the one and a half trillion
dollar bill it's part of the president's
new budget seeking huge spending
increases without even a pretense to
balance the books and that's new chief
White House correspondent John Roberts
starts us off tonight from the North
Lawn could even jump bracket evening for
decades successive American presidents
have talked about rebuilding America's
calcifying infrastructure but other than
a few roads and bridges here and there
there's been no coordinated plan to do
it president Trump hopes to change all
that but already there are complaints
about a meager federal investment with
the governors of several states and
local officials in attendance President
Trump today unveiled his plans to
reinvigorate America's aging
infrastructure as of a couple of months
ago we have spent seven trillion dollars
in the Middle East seven trillion
dollars what a mistake we're trying to
build roads and bridges and fix bridges
that are falling down and we have a hard
time getting the money it's crazy the
plan calls for a total of 1.5 to 1.7
trillion dollars in infrastructure
investment the federal share will be
about thirteen percent two hundred
billion dollars in seed money for grants
and loans the government will also
invest fifty billion dollars in rural
infrastructure development part of which
will bring broadband farms across the
nation their returns power to the state
and local governments who know best what
their people need Washington will no
longer be a roadblock to progress
Washington will now be a partner will be
your partner the president Trump pledged
to cut federal red tape for permitting
and get the process down to two years or
less but he warned states they need to
step up to the plate as well do we give
you money and you can't get your
approvals I guess we're gonna have to
take that money back or you're not gonna
build because we can't give your money
and you're gonna take 15 years to get a
permit and
state took 17 years for a basic roadway
to get a permit the white house today
was also short on details about when
officials first became aware of the
allegations of domestic abuse leveled at
former staff secretary Rob Porter look
we learned of the extent of the
situation involving Rob Porter last
Tuesday evening and within 24 hours his
resignation had been accepted and
announced the FBI has known about the
allegations and photos since January
25th of last year knew they could
disqualify Porter from holding a full
security clearance because of the
possibility of blackmail yet the White
House suggested today the FBI never
passed along that information it's
handled by our law enforcement and
intelligence community and we support
that process it's the same process that
has been used for decades for other in
previous administrations and we're
relying on that process at this point
I do think that it's up to those same
law enforcement and intelligence
agencies to determine if changes need to
be made to their process and the White
House today dodged questions about why
President Trump has twice personally
offered support to Rob Porter in
comments to reporters and on Twitter yet
he has not publicly spoken out against
domestic violence I spoke to him and he
relayed that message directly to me and
I'm relaying it directly to you but
clearly the White House has got a timing
problem too sources tell Fox News that
the FBI delivered the file on Rob Porter
to Don McGann the White House Counsel
back in November we also know that
Porter himself told him again about the
allegations that we are told he did not
include the most serious allegation of
the punching his first wife in the eye
now the timing of all of this is
important because if the White House
knew that Porter was never going to
receive his for his former land full
security clearance why Bret was he left
in the job and is there a sense that the
White House that the president is
preparing to come out and talk about
this again
not that we've seen Brett I mean we saw
him make the public statement about
Porter on Friday
saw him issue a public tweet on Saturday
yet when it comes to this issue of
domestic violence we've only heard from
people who work for him or surrogates
that he deplores domestic violence john
roberts live in the North Lawn John
thanks